welcome to scramble in Louisiana I love
you Isaac quests on how do you turn a
left over crossing into something
delicious well watch and learn
so glucose a croissant here we have some
beautiful Tasso this is a unique piece
of pork from a wild hog so it's been
cured briefly seasons and slightly
peppery very little fat but incredibly
delicious alongside that we're going to
use an all Bay seasoning with mayonnaise
hot sauce and sort of elevate this
croissant into something absolutely
delicious as always first I'll get that
pan nice and hot turn the gas now as I'm
waiting for that to get nice and hot
take your Tasso and this is a shoulder
look at it hardly any fat beauty cured
so just needs a quick flash bright and
what I'm gonna do is just slice nice
thin tiny rations and this is a
indigenous beautiful ham that is found
out here in some of the marshlands and
these hogs are fell running wild to
slice it nice and thin almost like
little rashes available once you see
that pan starting to smoke just a splash
of are all in there
lightly seasoned that pan just salt in
there get the salt toasting a lot after
that you get your class on okay and just
place that quest on in there okay and we
get that really nice and toasted
it's an on a season that you know it's a
very rich buttery pastry maybe lots of
layers set proven so you season the pan
a nice salty flavor goes through to
cross something that it turns it from
something sweet it does things savory
so just toast that first because the pan
starts smoking you know there's lots of
butter in those class on so just be
careful not to burn it as it toasts turn
that over beautiful muscle on there that
would be utiful color but that does now
it creates this beautiful foundation
this nice base in order to start
building this incredible breakfast
sandwich you can see the butter
listening now coming out come on there
sit on my plate ready to go and there's
mine it
again nice and crisp we'll set that on
the top at the end turn that gas down
and literally get that Tasso in there
now it's super spin so doesn't need that
long
it's nasty cured as you know so be
careful not to over fry over fryer will
turn salty but put some amazing flavor
on top of that breakfast sandwich
doesn't need salt joining cure why I'm
going to hit it with a little touch of
pepper
[Music]
I guess it's nice and peppery and then
format pork comes out just a touch of
all by just a tiny bit of all my CV and
then turn it over now
delicious
he's got to smell incredible
talking about 15-20 seconds each size
[Music]
from that take that out right now
you got nice
and crispy
now I want our flavor to remain in order
to fry the egg so not touch the olive
oil or butter in get a nice and hot and
then season that like that with a touch
of all back
okay get a nice and brown bag
into that take up the heat
on that egg to get really nice and
flavor especially nove
but I withdraw and we really made the
egg so taste the difference between a
plain Friday signal please let's let it
sit there let it continue looking nice
and slowly now for the five summer days
take two nights tablespoons of
mayonnaise a nice splash of a beautiful
hot sauce
depending out hot and liked it and then
from there a little seasonings of all
day fresh lemon that gives it that nice
acidity it cuts that heat down as well I
don't want this too thick okay on a nice
spicy mayonnaise but I don't want it too
heavy a lot of layers go on here butter
start the outside just face those eggs
see just make those eggs a little bit
peppery the gas is off I'm cooking the
eggs in the residual heat left in the
pan okay a nice spicy bun was that flag
back beautiful sticker now to make sure
you cook all that I'd base the yolk as
well so it doesn't run to crazily the
yolk stays in the croissant and not on
your chili now
mayonnaise I like it quite acidic so be
generous without a beautiful
lemon juice okay
from there now you got the heat in the
pan there nope last on the heat there
now get those eggs finished off a base
of the yolks to the yolk sort of almost
three-quarters coat and you see that
beautiful spice of those eggs it's sort
of list that yo can make the less rich a
little bit more spicy or touch more heat
in the pan right that the gas
beautiful backup for the gas now
when it comes to assembling this
and building this this is where it turns
into a really exciting sandwich
take your sauce the little touch of the
spicy mayonnaise on the bottom it's nice
and crisp so don't worry about it you
know so you take your lettuce and look
at the lettuce the size of the croissant
okay and build it we're we're just
protecting and don't have it overflow
too much
take out the hose and literally sit down
there and I such a seething in between
the layers really inform us
I cannot be nice thin slices of tomato
mr. beautiful big beats matter great for
breakfast and so tasty
I set that one to three on top it's nice
to see there
and then she's used to cheddar cheese
roller sit on top again
but my sauce on there get your bacon
thank you I just want to lay the sauce
taso Hulk Chris penis over there I put
for the same shape put it the way the
croissants shape okay sir
useful to us by inside tasty
most often there and then with you a
spice
[Music]
system that nation
just she has to touch the lambdas all
that is the drop now beautiful spicy
mayonnaise
from that too
and then we have beautiful the breakfast
sandwich let me know in the comments
what you think of that amazing scrambled
egg dish and if you missed uncharted
trust me you can watch it on the link
below or on the NatGeo app
[Music]